okay. I regularly receive videos of interactions
with police from people in the audience. Usually
I don't end up talking about them on the show
because they don't see anything interesting
or the circumstances seem very blurry. I don't
a a blurry or a gray area. Maybe not literally
blurry video, but just as unclear exactly
what's going on. There's nothing interesting.
I don't think there's any interesting points
to be made, but in the past, there have been
some times that we successfully put a spotlight
on interactions between police and citizens.
And one example is back in 2015 I received
a video from Ohio of a black man being pulled
over for quote, making direct eye contact
with a police officer. That clip ended up
getting nearly 300,000 youtube views, but
more it actually led to a meeting between
the black man and the white officer. And I
believe in apology and maybe even further
training for officers. It was a really great
thing that was able to come of it. I have
another video for you today and another one
of these stories that I do want to talk about.
And this one is from Fairfax County, Virginia.
And it involves a young black man, uh, back
in March, the video was only recently made
available sitting in his car at a red light,
driving home from work. And before I tell
you the story, uh, make sure that you subscribe,
like, and share this video.
If you're watching it on youtube, we want
this to be widely seen. That's how it will
have the widest impact. So subscribe like
the video and share it as the story has been
told to me. An officer Bush badge number four
zero seven, seven started following the young
black man made eye contact as the officer
past the black man. The officer then makes
a u-turn in the middle of the street to get
right behind this young man and follows the
man into his neighborhood and all the way
to his apartment building. In fact, at which
point the driver parks and the officer approaches
the man and starts asking questions that don't
seem quite right given the circumstances,
including claiming not to believe that the
young black man actually lives in the apartment
complex into which they've pulled. Uh, despite
the fact that, uh, as I've been told the story,
there is actually a resident parking sticker
on the driver's side of the vehicle, driven
by the young black man that associates it
with the apartment complex into which they
pulled. So we have video and I want to show
you the video. And there's a lot of concerning
things here. Let's look at clip number one.
Hey, please, sir, how are you doing? Doing
well. How are you? Hey, good. Hey, do you
live here? I do, yes. Okay. Where do you live
at? In this apartment? Right here. Okay. You
gotta Id on, you know, I know you have id.
I do have an id but I have to show to you.
You don't have id on him. I do have an idea.
Okay. Do we have to share it to you? You don't
have to. Is this your car? Yes it is. Okay.
Is there a problem? What building do you live
in? This building right here. What's the address?
I don't have to say. I don't tell you. I want
to tell you the address. What's that? Do I
need to tell you the address? Yeah. What's
the address? Why do I need to tell you my
address? No, I'm asking you what the address
is. So why do I need to tell you that?
Cause I'm asking you.
Well, is there a reason why you're asking
me? Because I want to know if you live here
because we don't live here and I just told
you I do live here, right? But if you don't
know the address, do you live here? So
notice that there's a series of questions,
none of which seem to have any relation to
reasonable suspicion of a crime having been
committed. The driver knows his rights and
his asserting them and then it gets to the
crux of what the officer said there. It doesn't
look like to me that you live here. You don't
look like you live here. What would be the
reason for that? What about this man who knows
his rights and has done nothing to warrant
suspicion of a crime? What about appearance
suggests to the officer that he doesn't really
live in the apartment complex in which he
claims to live? Now I know that there will
be people who will say, David, the driver
is being obstinate. Just give your ID, state
the address and you'll be on your way. And
this is exactly the problem. This is called
phishing.
The officer asserts no reason why he's following
and now asking repeated questions to this
individual. The driver realizes that the officer
is fishing and he doesn't provide more information.
And your reaction is that the driver is the
problem here. By the way, again, the driver
reportedly has a parking sticker for that
parking complex, that apartment complex, uh,
in a window on the driver's side. But again,
he doesn't have to engage with this stuff
if he doesn't want to. So let's continue where,
uh, he goes back to the car, uh, questions
about the car and questions about how long
the individual has lived in the area.
Okay. And why is that? Why is that? Who's
vehicles? This is my vehicle. Was it in your
name and said my mom's name is and my name.
Melissa. Okay. How long have you lived in
this area? And do I have to tell you that
I'm just asking you a question. Okay. But
why are you asking me these questions?
So you live here or not? Sir, I hear already
told you I do live here. Okay. Cause if you
don't live here, you're trespassing. I know
that. And I told you I live here. Okay, so
what's the address that you live at? Why do
I have to tell you that? Cause I don't believe
you live here, sir. And why don't you believe
me? Why don't you believe I live here? Because
you don't know the address. Are you too? Would
you? I do know the address. Okay. What's the
address that you live? I don't have to tell
you that I land for. Why are you harassing
me? Okay. I'm not harassing you. You're in
my neighborhood coming up to me telling me,
asking me what my address is. Cause you say
I don't live here. Why don't you believe I
live here? If
you don't live here, then you're trespassing.
Do you have reason to believe that I'm trespassing?
I mean again, other than the fact that you
said, I don't look like I live here, the driver
doesn't have to do the police officer's job
for him and good for the driver for saying,
you're telling me you don't believe I live
here, but why are you even talking to me right
now? These questions are questions meant to
try to trip up or create a an apparent contradiction
or even just to further make the driver nervous
as the driver understandably is as you can
hear in his voice so that he then does something
justifying further interaction with the officer,
whether it's searching the car, pulling the
driver out, whatever, and the driver. You
hear the nervousness in his voice, but he
doesn't take the bait and I think that's good.
Now this is a good point for, for me to make
now this is not about messing with police,
okay? This is about police messing with drivers
who have done nothing wrong that police can
articulate that would create suspicion of
any kind that a crime may have been committed
by this person. I am not one of these folks.
You see these videos on youtube where I'm
about seeking out border patrol checkpoints
to refuse to id or answer questions to make
interesting youtube videos. I'm not about
that. I think that that's generally a waste
of time. I'm not into driving deliberately
into sobriety checkpoints and trying to interfere
with the checkpoint, whatever. Right? That.
That's not, that's not why I, I personally
find that to be a waste of time. That's different
here. That's not what's going on. This is
an individual who is just driving home. When
this officer decided this is someone that
I'm going to talk to and start asking repeated,
harassing questions, often you will hear,
well, the driver generally matched the description
of someone we were looking for. Police will
say that, uh, that wasn't said here and it
hasn't been asserted after the fact, even
though an investigation has been opened up.
Let's now watch the end of the interaction.
Sir, I'm not harassing you. [inaudible] have
your name and best number you can detective
Bush. And my badge number is four zero seven
seven. Okay, thank you. So do you have an
id on you or not? I do. I already told you
I do have an id. What's your name? I don't
have to tell you that. Am I being insane?
Am I free to go? You're free to go, sir. Thank
you. Have a good day. You too. Thank you.
Ultimately getting to the key question, am
I being detained or am I free to go? Detective
Bush ultimately realizes he has no business
trying to detain this person. He has no justification
for the detaining this individual. And uh,
the right question was ultimately asked, am
I free to go? And the answer was yes. This
is a guy driving around. An officer decides
that absent any evidence or reason for suspicion,
he's gonna mess with this guy and see what
he can find. He's going fishing. Let me throw
my fishing line in the water and see if there's
fish because why not? Maybe I'll catch something
and it gets worse because the officer stayed
at the apartment complex just watching this
guy for a while, a half hour, one additional
video, just eight seconds to show you.
Okay?
And there's the officer continuing to wait
around in the parking lot. I don't know more
about this right now. Okay. You now have all
the information that I have. I was sent this,
I watched all of these videos multiple times
in detail. Let's see what comes comes of this.
I'm told that internal affairs is now investigating
this. Knowing and asserting your rights when
you were being confronted by police for no
reason is not being obstinate. And this guy
did the right thing. A lot of people don't
know what their rights are in these situations
despite being clearly nervous. You hear the
agitation in the black man's voice and I understand
it. Uh, he asserted his rights, he remained
calm and it doesn't always go this way. There
are times when merely asserting your rights
in the way that this individual did can actually
get you pulled out of the car and can get
the vehicle searched.
And there is a risk associated with this approach.
We'll see what comes of it. Um, this is a,
a police department that, uh, whose demographics
are drastically out of line with the demographics
of the community, which they police. And this
is an issue that's a much broader issue in
the United States that we've talked about
before. Pete Buddha judge actually brought
this up at the recent Democratic presidential
debate. Uh, so let me know what you think
about this as, as soon as I have more information,
I will give it to you because this is all
I have so far. Uh, please remember to subscribe,
like, and share this video. We do want as
many people to see it as possible.
We'll take a quick break, make sure you're
following the show on Instagram at David Pakman
show. Follow me on Instagram at David Dot.
Packman it as well, the David Pakman show